As a movie based on an attraction in Disneyland,
"Jungle Cruise" is chock full of Easter eggs and
other small nods to the ride's Adventureland
home. Here are some you may have missed.
A fictional character in the Jungle
Cruise/Adventureland universe,
Dr. Albert Falls was introduced in the attraction
as a joke - the namesake of the famous
Schweitzer Falls, which he "discovered."
Albert Falls' characterization grew with the
expansion of the Jungle Cruise backstory in 2015.
Now, Albert's books and other items
found on his travels are featured
on shelves in the Skipper Canteen
restaurant, and there's a bronze
bust of the famed fictional explorer in
Trader Sam's at the Disneyland Hotel.
In the "Jungle Cruise" film, Dr. Albert Falls is
an offscreen character whose travel documents,
maps, and an arrowhead are sought after
by Dr. Lily Houghton and Prince Joachim
in their search for the coveted healing
tree. In the beginning of the movie,
Lily breaks into and snoops around an English
archaeological society's archives and finds
the arrow she's looking for inside a crate
labeled with "Dr. A. Falls." Albert Falls
is also briefly mentioned a couple of other
times in the film when Lily and Frank are
discussing the exploration of the Amazon
and the search for the "tears of the moon."
Founded by the aforementioned Dr. Albert Falls,
the Jungle Navigation Company Ltd. is a fictional
business set within the Adventureland
and Jungle Cruise world of Disney parks.
It's the parent company and operator of the
Jungle Cruise tours of the world's rivers
and also boasts the popular Skipper Canteen mess
hall-style eatery. The company was introduced to
Disneyland's and Magic Kingdom's Adventureland
as part of updates to the parks in the 1990s.
The Jungle Navigation Company's Skipper Canteen
menu is also full of nods to the Jungle Cruise
attraction, including dishes named after Albert
Falls and the attraction's boats. There's also
a "Not Piranha" sustainable fish dish, which is
made all the more funny after seeing Frank serve
up fresh piranha in the "Jungle Cruise" movie.
In the film, a sign bearing the Jungle Navigation
Company Ltd. logo can be seen at the docks
as Frank tries to get out of paying Nilo.
Fans of Disneyland's Enchanted
Tiki Room were likely thrilled
to see a brief but memorable "Jungle
Cruise" cameo by Rosita the cockatoo.
The white-feathered Rosita is one of the "showgirl
birds" who appear in the attraction and sing
"Let's All Sing Like the Birdies Sing." However,
Rosita's spot on the mobile is empty because she
left the group for adventures elsewhere. She
now inhabits various spots around Disneyland,
including the Tropical Hideaway and a
riverside cage on the Jungle Cruise attraction.
In the "Jungle Cruise" film,
Paul Giamatti's character, Nilo,
has a pet cockatoo named Rosita, who repeatedly
squawks the memorable line "Frank owes me money."
It's the eighth wonder of the world and one of
the greatest continuous jokes in theme park ride
history: the backside of water. Jungle Cruise ride
fans will laugh at this joke no matter how many
times they've heard it and seen the other side
of the famous Schweitzer Falls. Boat skippers
tell passengers they like to call it "O2H."
In the "Behind the Attraction" series on Disney+,
imagineers behind the Jungle Cruise ride and
some longtime skippers said the backside of
water joke is an essential part of the
experience. If the joke isn't told,
guests will remind the skippers of their misstep.
Likewise, including the backside of water joke was
a must for the "Jungle Cruise" film. It was
featured prominently in the first trailer:
"Ladies and gentlemen, the moment you've
been waiting for ... the backside of water."
That joke, and all the others Frank deadpans,
elicit groans and eye rolls from the tourists.
In a similar nod to the human-made river cruise
at Disneyland, the character Frank is shown to
have rigged many of the tricks in the water
and along the shore to give his boat tour a
more adventurous feel. To create the backside of
water, he put together a system of water troughs
and pulleys to produce a small waterfall at
the best moment to deliver the one-liner.
The Jungle Cruise ride we know and love today
isn't the same one that ferried passengers
along the world's rivers on Disneyland's
opening day in 1955. For almost a decade,
nature and wildlife education was the focus
of the original Jungle Cruise attraction.
The corny "dad jokes" and dry humor didn't
make it into the ride until the 1960s.
Alongside the backside of water, skippers
now make jokes about a group of lions
eating a zebra "on the rocks" and sharing
the meal "with pride." There's also the
Nile crocodile named Ginger who ... snaps.
The skippers call her "one tough cookie."
Johnson's character Frank really leans into the
punny skipper role in "Jungle Cruise." When hegestures to some sandstone rocks, Frank says
"The rocks you see here are sandstone. Butsome people just take them for granite."
As Frank continues, his audience's groans
and eye rolls grow in intensity. He even prompts
a silent "wow" from one passenger after saying he
got "canned" from his previous job at an orange
juice factory because "I couldn't concentrate."
Later in the movie, when Frank, Lily and
McGregor are being taken to the village
of native "headhunters," Frank says
it's not a great place to "be headed."
The Jungle Cruise wouldn't be the Jungle Cruise
without its animatronic animals, especially the
hippos. In the Disneyland ride, the boat slowly
moves through the hippo pool while the skipper
tells the passengers to stay still so as not to
rock the boat and disturb the massive animals.
At one point, the skipper "fires" a fake pistol
to scare some of the hippos away from the boat.
A brief but similar scene happens
in the "Jungle Cruise" movie. As
Frank narrates the many ways the Amazon
jungle has killed previous explorers,
the boat rumbles past a stationary
fake hippo protruding from the water.
Then, as Frank is activating a bunch of his
tricks to entertain the passengers, he uses
a pistol kept near the boat's wheel to fire at
a rope and unleash the mechanical roaring hippo.
Hippos aren't native to the Amazon region - a
fact pointed out by a young girl on the boat,
whom Frank shushes - so they aren't
seen again in the rest of the film.
At the beginning of 2021, the Jungle Cruise
ride received some major storytelling updates
to get rid of "negative depictions of
native people," which included getting
rid of the unofficial Jungle Cruise
mascot, the Trader Sam animatronic.
Though Trader Sam had different animatronic
iterations in Disneyland and Magic Kingdom,
the character was described by critics as a
racist caricature of Indigenous African peoples.
Trader Sam got another revamp in the "Jungle
Cruise" movie. In the film, Veronica Falcón
portrays Trader Sam as the leader of the tribe
of Indigenous people who guard the healing tree.
She makes several quips about "working" with Frank
in playing outdated stereotypes of native peoples
for his river cruise story and how she makes
money off of colonial notions of her people.
The portrayal of Trader Sam and her people
doesn't always hit the nail on the head when
it comes to reimagining the character. There is a
moment when Trader Sam dons Lily's brother's top
hat in a small nod to the Magic Kingdom version
of Trader Sam, who's not only holding several
shrunken heads but also wearing one as a necklace.
But critics have said the new Trader Sam is a,
quote, "hearty attempt to reimagine a
less racist version of the character."
This one may be a bit of a stretch, but
Prince Joachim's submarine is strangely
reminiscent of the Nautilus vessel from
Disney's "20,000 Leagues Under the Sea."
Though the interior of the submarine is cold and
cramped, Joachim somehow also has extravagant,
luxurious quarters that solidify his
bumbling caricature of a colonizing villain.
The famous Nautilus submarine was created by
Jules Verne and featured in his 1870 novel "20,000
Leagues Under the Sea" and in the Disney film of
the same name from 1954. The Nautilus is shaped
like a fish and has a shingled ramming fern at the
bow. Joachim's submarine boasts a similar serrated
ramming fern at its bow, but so did many other
German UB-II-type submarines during World War I.
Magic Kingdom at Disney World had a 20,000 Leagues
Under the Sea attraction that featured a 20-minute
submarine ride aboard an adapted version of
Nautilus, but the ride was shuttered in 1994.
The 1951 adventure classic "The African Queen" is
one of the key elements that inspired the layout
and storytelling of the original Jungle Cruise
boat ride in Disneyland. Seventy years later, its
inspiration lives on in the "Jungle Cruise" film.
The film is based on the 1935 novel of the same
name and stars Humphrey Bogart as a skipper
ferrying a woman played by Katharine Hepburn
down a river in a boat named the African
Queen. The movie is also set during World
War I and has long been heralded by
critics as thrilling, adventurous,
and funny with a hint of lighthearted romance.
While "Jungle Cruise" is obviously based on
the theme park attraction, it clearly also
takes inspiration from "The African Queen."
Looper's review of the film said Johnson's Frank
"looks like the human growth hormone version
of Bogart" with Blunt's character giving "her
ambitious scientist a little glint of Hepburn."
Frank also sports a nearly identical
skipper outfit to Bogart's Charlie Allnut,
complete with a red scarf tied around
his neck and a black-billed white cap.
The design of Frank's creaky, hodgepodge riverboat
also pays homage to Charlie's African Queen.
Though "Jungle Cruise" is set in 1916, it does
have a nod to "Disney's True-Life Adventure"
nature documentaries, which premiered in the
late 1940s, ran through 1960, and inspired the
original Jungle Cruise attraction at Disneyland.
During a quieter moment in "Jungle Cruise,"
Blunt's character Lily uses a box camera to
capture motion pictures of the wildlife and
scenery of the jungle while sailing down
the Amazon River. She captures soundless,
black and white shots of butterflies, birds,
and foliage while Johnson's Frank stares in awe.
He's never seen a motion picture camera
before, so Lily lets him try it out.
Lily also explains the excitement of
motion pictures and how they can bring
any place in the world right to you. It's a
similar sentiment shared by Walt Disney and
his team when shooting and sharing the
"True-Life Adventure" features as well
as creating the Jungle Cruise ride. Both the
feature and attraction were made to bring the
world to an audience — and give that audience
a greater appreciation for wildlife and nature.
Yes, veteran heavy metal rockers Metallica
reworked an orchestral version of "Nothing
Else Matters" for a key scene in
Disney's "Jungle Cruise" movie.
It's an unexpected but delightful detail that
somehow fits in a flashback scene set in the
mid-1500s with Spanish conquistadors and a tribe
of Indigenous people in the Amazonian rainforest.
Metallica drummer Lars Ulrich talked about
the Disney collaboration in September 2020,
saying it goes back to "lifelong rock fan" Sean
Bailey, who is Disney's production president.
Ulrich worked with "Jungle Cruise" score composer
James Newton Howard to rearrange "Nothing Else
Matters" into a piece that's instrumental
to the dark, frenzied scene. In an interview
with Collider, Ulrich said the version is
a "very unusual" morph of the iconic song.
The flashback scene is quick and feels a bit
jammed with a lot of plot points that can be
hard to follow, but the new arrangement
of "Nothing Else Matters" is a dizzying,
welcome addition to a score otherwise
filled with spirited adventure ballads.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.